>> Kayleigh: MIGRANT ENCODERS
OF THE BORDER HIT A 21 YEAR HIGH
LAST MONTH WITH AGENTS DETAINING
MORE THAN 200,000 MIGRANTS ON
419% INCREASE OVER LAST YEAR.
HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
ALEJANDRO MERRICK US WAS OF THE
BORDER YESTERDAY CALLING THE
SITUATION COMPLICATED IN
ASSISTING THE BORDERS CLOSE.
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID
PRIVATELY TO BORDER OFFICIALS IN
LEAKED AUDIO FOX NEWS HAS
OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY.
>> UNSUSTAINABLE.
THESE NUMBERS CANNOT CONTINUE.
WE CANNOT GET TO A POINT WHERE
WE WERE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
WE HAVE TO MAKE FOR THAT DOESN’T
HAPPEN.
LOOKING AT ALL THE POLICY
OPTIONS.
OUR PEOPLE IN THE FIELD.
I KNOW VERY WELL HOW CLOSE THE
EVENT OF BREAKING HERE IN THIS
SECTOR.
IT’S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
>> Kayleigh: WOW, HARRIS,
THERE’S A WORD WE’VE HEARD
REPEATEDLY FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS THE WORD
PROGRESS.
KAMALA HARRIS THAT WE HAVE MADE
PROGRESS ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS HAS USED THAT
WORD, JEN PSAKI HAS USE THAT
WORD.
PROGRESS, PROGRESS, PROGRESS.
IT’S A STUNNING, DIFFERENT
VERBIAGE BEING USED IN PRIVATE
BEHIND THE SCENES.
>> Harris: WE NEED
TRANSPARENCY AND WHAT THEIR PLAN
LOOKS LIKE ON WHAT PROGRESS
ACTUALLY MEANS TO THEM, HOW THEY
ARE MEASURING IT.
IF THEY ARE MEASURING PROGRESS
BY, WE SENT SOMEBODY DOWN THERE
AND THAT PERSON TALK PRIVATELY,
AT LEAST WE THOUGHT IT WAS
PRIVATE, AND GAY PEOPLE KIND OF
AN OUT-OF-THE-WAY PAN ON THE
BACK AND GAVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT
WE NEED TO DO NEXT, THAT’S ONE
THING.
BUT IF PROGRESS IS WHAT IT
SHOULD BE AND THAT IS SOLVING
THE CRISIS AND THE PROBLEMS AND
TURNING OFF THE SPIGOT AND
PUTTING ON A MORATORIUM.
IT’S A WHOLE DIFFERENT BALL OF
WAX.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY’RE
LOOKING AT.
WHICH I GUESS IS WHAT ALLOWED
THE PRESIDENT TO SAY TO SOMEONE
LIKE CUOMO, YOU KNOW, BASICALLY,
HECK OF A CKJO OF A JOB IN THE M
SCANDAL THAT CAUSED HIM TO QUIT,
A SEX SCANDAL.
I GUESS IF YOUR IDEA OF PROGRESS
IS YOU JUST WENT THERE OR PHONED
THEM, THATE BUT WHAT WE
NEED NOW WITH NEARLY A QUARTER
MILLION PEOPLE COMING THE BORDER
-- COMING ACROSS THE BOERNER,
THAT’S BIGGER THAN MOST CITIES
IN AMERICA.
IF THAT’S WHAT WE’RE LOOKING FOR
YOU GOING TO HAVE TO TURN OFF
THE SPIGOT.
ANDY BIGGS FROM ARIZONA, SEVERAL
ARE BANDING TOGETHER AND SAYING
WE NEED TO IMPEACH MAYORKAS TO
FORCE HIM TO GET THE ATTENTION
OF THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
PROGRESS LOOKS LIKE DOING YOUR
JOB.
LET’S ASK HIM.
NEXT WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING.
WHAT IS PROGRESS TO YOU?
>> Kayleigh: GREAT QUESTION.
I HOPE ONE OF THE CORRESPONDENCE
ASKS THAT.
WE ALSO HEARD MAYORKAS SAY IT’S
IMPORTANT NEVER TO UNDERSTATE
THE SITUATION.
IN THAT SAME LEAKED AUDIO HE
CALLED THE SITUATION
UNSUSTAINABLE.
WE ALMOST LOST A SECTOR.
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE.
THERE IS A SECTOR THAT’S AT THE
POINT OF BREAKING.
HE’S UNDERSTATING IT VERY
CLEARLY PUBLICLY SAYING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT PRIVATELY.
>> Morgan: KAYLEIGH, I THOUGHT
THE LEAKED AUDIO IS FASCINATING
BECAUSE I HEARD A DHS SECRETARY
WHO CLEARLY IS VERY FRUSTRATED
THAT HE CAN’T DO HIS JOB.
IT WAS SOMEONE BEHIND THE
SCENES.
I THINK I AGREED WITH A LOT OF
WHAT HE WAS SAYING.
HE WAS SAYING ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS SHOULD BE ILLEGAL.
HE KNEW IT WAS A PROBLEM THAT
THEY NEEDED TO KEEP TITLE 42 AND
WAS EVIDENT FROM YOU, THE
DIFFERENCE IN THAT LEAKED AUDIO
VERSUS WHAT HE IS SAYING
PUBLICLY IS EVIDENCE TO ME THAT
HE’S NOT BEING ALLOWED TO DO HIS
JOB.
NOT BEING ALLOWED TO PUT
POLICIES IN PLACE THAT HE KNOWS
WOULD STOP THE FLOW AT THE
BORDER.
THE QUESTION IS WHY.
I THINK IT’S BECAUSE THIS
ADMINISTRATION TRULY DOES NOT
CARE IF HE’S MIGRANTS ARE COMING
OVER ILLEGALLY.
THEY JUST DON’T.
>> Kayleigh: THEY DON’T.
YOU KNOW MORGAN HAS A POINT.
HE’S SAYING THINGS THAT WOULDN’T
PUBLICLY ALLOWED TO BE SAID.
HE WENT ON TO PRAISE THE HEROIC
EFFORTS OF THE BORDER AGENT
SAYING I’M GOING TO TRY TO GET
YOU HAZARD PAY BECAUSE THEY ARE
DEALING WITH COVID.
HE TALKED ABOUT INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF AGENTS, HE TALKED
ABOUT ICE TAKING A BIGGER ROLE,
THE SAME I SEE THAT THE LEFT
WANTS TO ABOLISH.
IS IT UNTENABLE FOR HIM TO SAY
THESE THINGS PUBLICLY BECAUSE OF
THE AOC WING OF THE PARTY THAT
HAS SUCH A GROUP OF WHAT’S GOING
ON?
>> Dagen: I THINK HE IS SAYING
THEY WOULD RATHER TALK THAN
WALK.
THEY WOULD RATHER TRY TO CONTROL
LANGUAGE, ALSO FASCIST.
RATHER THAN IMPLEMENT POLICIES
OR LEAVE POLICIES IN PLACE THAT
KEPT OUR BORDER SECURITY.
AND KEPT DRUG TRAFFICKERS AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS FROM PROFITING
OFF HUMAN MISERY AND SUFFERING,
WHETHER IT’S TRAFFICKING DRUGS
OR CHILDREN.
EARLIER JEN PSAKI WOULDN’T CALL
IT A CRISIS.
SHE REFERRED TO IT AS A
CHALLENGE.
WE CAN TAKE A SLIVER OF SOLACE
IN THE FACT THAT SECRETARY
MAYORKAS AT LEAST PRIVATELY
ACKNOWLEDGES WHAT WE CAN SEE
WITH OUR OWN EYES IN TERMS OF
THE VIDEO THAT WE HAVE SHOT, IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE ARE HEARING,
WHETHER IT’S NEW MAYORS OR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS UP AND THE
BORDER, LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS
COMING IN MONTHLY OF THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF APPREHENSIONS AND MORE
IN MORE THAN TWO DECADES.
I THINK THE ONLY THING THAT
COULD TURN IT AROUND HIS POLL
NUMBERS HAVE MOVED AGAINST THIS
ADMINISTRATION SO MUCH.
ONLY 35% APPROVE OF HANDLING OF
IMMIGRATION.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT THE POLLS
THAN THE HUMAN SUFFERING.
MAYBE THIS GETS THEM OFF FAIR
YOU KNOW WHATS TO DEAL WITH THE
CRISIS THAT’S AFFECTING SO MANY
AMERICANS.
>> Kayleigh: THERE IS NOTHING
LIKE POLLING MOTIVATING
POLITICIANS TO FINALLY ACT.
ONCE AGENTS STOOD UP TO MAYORKAS
SAYING THIS, FOR THOSE OF US
WHO’VE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH
WE DON’T NEED TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL.
SEEN THIS HAPPEN BEFORE.
WE KNOW HOW TO SHUT IT DOWN.
WE NEED TO MAKE ILLEGAL ENTRY
ILLEGAL.
THAT’S ON-SITE COMMON SENSE FROM
SOMEONE ON THE GROUND.
>> Dan: IT’S ALWAYS GOOD TO
LISTEN TO THE GUYS AND GALS ON
THE GROUND, THEY USUALLY KNOW
THE SITUATION BEST.
I THINK THERE’S THREE THINGS
THIS ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO BE
DOING AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE
FIRST ONE WHICH ISN’T ADMIT
PUBLICLY WE HAVE A CRISIS OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
SECONDLY WE’VE GOT TO THROW MORE
RESOURCES OF THIS CHALLENGE,
THIS CRISIS.
SECRETARY MAYORKAS TALKED ABOUT
INCREASING THE NUMBER BORDER
PATROL AGENTS.
OUR FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE BY
2,000 IN 2023, I THINK THIS
CRISIS DEMANDS MORE IMMEDIATE
ACTION, MORE TECHNOLOGY AND MORE
PEOPLE.
THIRD, WE HAVEN’T HAD
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
SINCE 1986.
BOTH PARTIES NEED TO COME